hallo mein name ist so kann heftig
bekommen wir heute zu einem neuen video
über alle schon nicht mit meiner neuen
wohnung ist halt noch so ein bisschen
als dafür bitte ich mich auf damit ich
mich selbst ich bitte mich selbst dafür
zu entschuldigen
ich will dass viele gar nicht so lange
halten heute kamen ja schon ein video
das von dem ich euch hier irgendwo war
teil eins war es vor zwei tagen ist mein
schiff geladen - statt und es war so
krank wie viele leute von euch darauf
war wie viele fest bestellt haben und
vor allem auch was wir uns für eine
geduld entgegengebracht haben weil wir
hatten mega die server probleme weil so
viele leute drauf an wie hatten
irgendwie insgesamt 90.000 zugriffe pro
sekunde bisher nicht mehr einfach
gedacht und da ist auch wenn zeit jetzt
ist ich schenke euch etwas ich erkläre
das ganze mal los war es ja heute
samstag der dritte dezember das heißt
heute könnt ihr was gewinnen nächste
woche samstag in zehnten dezember danach
wie woche samstag den 17 dezember und
dann nach heiligabend also dem 24
dezember und das um alle samstage
deswegen war ich einkaufen habe ein
iphone 7 gekauft
sibel in much work too eine canon
powershot gmx markt weit vom bloggen und
videos aufnimmt ennetacher de 7x nach
zwei metern
der neue 3ds nintendo 3ds und eine
playstation 4 wird einem spiel mit den
beispiel mit dabei mit dem controller
playstation 4 2 spielen controller
ich bin nicht so der fan davon welch
gute einen zu rauszuhauen und das finde
ich so ein bisschen kalt deswegen habe
mit eur flughafens nichts gekauft was
man spielt denkt noch besser wenn ihr
ein produkt hiervon gewinnen sollte
bekommt ihr dabei auch einen usb stick
und auf dem usb-stick wird ein
persönliches video seine von mir für
euch die zehn minuten ruhig lawo ich
irgendetwas da gehört habe ist so ein
bisschen doch auch persönliches von mir
mit dabei ich sage jetzt stellen wir den
ganzen gewinnspiel teilnehmen können das
einzige was wir machen müssen ist
erstens meinen kanal abonnieren und
zweitens in die kommentare einen
kommentar schreiben wie ich euch
erreichen kann also ist beispielsweise
die kommentare hey du kannst bei twitter
erreichen teilt sie dort jetzt kaka pups
neuen oder halo k
twitter habe ich nicht aber ich hab'
instagram übergang als ich tanze lady
790 da kann es mich erreichen einfach
euren social media namen gegen
reinschreiben also zweiter hinter sachen
er
einfach bei den kanal abonnieren und
zweitens einfach einen kommentar
schreiben wie ich euch am besten
erreichen kann
ich freue mich jetzt vielleicht hält
welches von den vier sachen kann ich
denn jetzt heute am ersten samstag
vielleicht gewinnen also abonniert
meinen kanal schreibt den kommentare die
ich euch alle daten können die flächen
vielleicht nächsten samstag euch und das
war jetzt nicht zu sagen überhaupt
völlig um
wäre es nicht zu sagen ich hab euch alle
ganz toll weil der gewinner bekommen
eine playstation suite mit dem
persönlichen video
[Musik]